yesterday mixer announced that they'll
be ceasing their operations completely
Microsoft's answer to twitch and the
organization that signed shroud and
ninja to multi-million dollar
exclusivity deals is no more and they're
sending all their users order to
facebook gaming so how did this happen
and where do we go next
what's next for shrouded ninja let me
break it all
[Music]
all right before we get into this big
news I gotta remind you head over to
twitch.tv slash the score eSports and
give us a follow we'll be going live
Wednesday at 1:00 p.m. Eastern with our
talk show clouded where we're definitely
gonna go even deeper on this mix reviews
so make sure you tune in ok so just
after 2 p.m. Eastern on Monday afternoon
mixer announced that they'd be ceasing
operation and sending all their users
over to Facebook gaming who they're
partnering with just like that the
platform that was supposed to finally
rival twitches pseudo monopoly over the
live streaming world was no more and the
internet including myself was shocked
here's the statement that mixer posted
with the announcement ultimately the
success of partners and streamers on
mixer is dependent on our ability to
scale the service for them as quickly
and broadly as possible it became clear
that the time needed to grow our live
streaming community to scale was out of
measure with the vision and experiences
we want to delivers to gamers now so
we've decided to close the operation
side of mixer and help the community
transition to a new platform to better
serve our community's needs we're
teaming up with Facebook to enable the
mixer community to transition to
Facebook gaming ok so that incredibly
difficult to understand statement leads
to a few questions first and foremost
what happens to shrouded ninja what
happens to those mixer partners that
rely on this platform for income and
perhaps most importantly who the [ __ ]
uses Facebook gaming but first for those
of you who've been living under a rock
let me take you back to where this whole
thing started on August 1st 2019 ninja
was more or less larger than life he was
bringing fortnight and live streaming
into the mainstream in a huge way I mean
the guy was streaming with Travis Scott
Drake some people hated him some people
loved him but we couldn't deny that he
was huge and on that day he made a big
move he signed an exclusive deal to move
from twitch to mixer and more or less
broke the Internet as of today I will be
streaming exclusively on mixer
I know I know it's exciting this deal
opened the floodgates one single
exclusive deal and all of a sudden it
changed everything about what it means
to be a big streamer no more relying on
subs and donors and grinding for viewers
you could sign a deal that would pay you
to stream just like an athlete or an
actor streaming had gone Hollywood and
then shroud went to mixer and over the
next few months the biggest names in
streaming all started to sign deals with
twitch YouTube Facebook and mixer I'm
joining YouTube
[Music]
a moment your Facebook gaming check me
out there by I'm happy to announce I was
staying on twitch.tv slash Tim the tap
man hear that Kevin we're not going
anywhere
the streamer wars were completely under
way and they've continued ever since but
in the case of mixer those signings
never really felt like they moved the
needle sure I'd pop over and I'd watch
Shroud play Ballard when it came out or
the new war zone patch but by no means
did it feel like people were becoming
mixer viewers both ninjas and shroud saw
massive reductions in viewership on
their new platform but why would they
care they have a salary now they don't
have to grind for viewers anymore
basically what I'm saying here is
despite the moves it never really felt
like mixer crept into our daily lives as
people who like games and then kovin 19
happened and according to shroud and
mixer that was a massive blow to the
platform and the plans they had for
their two star acquisitions if what we
wanted to do with the ninja brand is
obviously continue to blow it up outside
of gaming which by the way this whole
corona [ __ ] has kind of destroyed those
opportunities you know because we I'm
not gonna be going anyway you know I'm
not gonna be going on live shows right
now and flying around like I'm trying to
you know practice social distancing and
be smart and lead by example we had a
lot of plans like me and Microsoft and
mixer we had a lot of plans to do very
very cool advertising and then Corona
started to happen and then started to
you know we're starting taking
precautions there and all of those
opportunities and all of those things
that we were going to do no longer exist
it definitely seems like there was this
big plan to gallivant these two guys
across the world and advertise for mixer
and that was obviously completely turned
on its head by the fact that they
couldn't leave their house for months
and that brings us to now in less than a
month mixer will be dead and standing in
its place is Facebook gaming who could
with this big move become the rival to
twitch that we always thought mixer
would be that said apparently you won't
be finding ninja or shroud on Facebook
gaming because on Monday afternoon
slasher and eSports personality known
for tweeting breaking news tweeted this
quote sources Facebook offered an insane
offer and almost doubled the original
mixer contracts of ninja and shroud but
loaded slash ninja slash shroud said no
and forced mixer to buy the meadow ninja
made thirty million from mixer and
shroud made ten million
ninja and shroud are now free agents
imagine your employer collapses the
platform you work on and then you get
paid thirty million dollars and can walk
out the door tomorrow and try to find a
new contract to sign at least early on
it looks like shroud and ninja made out
pretty well here it took them a few
hours to finally make a statement on
Twitter but when they did they kind of
gave us what you'd expect they loved
their mixture communities and they're
thinking about their next steps after
the dust settles we might see ninja and
trad back on twitch where this all
started
and I'm sure Amazon will be stoked to
have them okay so at this point you're
probably asking yourself how did this
happen how did a platform backed by a
company as big as Microsoft failed was
it just that kovat 19 stuff I was
talking about and in the statement I
read earlier Microsoft doesn't really
give us much to go off of they use
phrases like they couldn't grow their
lives reading platform to scale and it
wasn't in line with the vision that
Microsoft and Xbox had for this
community going forward in words that
real people can understand it just
wasn't big enough and it didn't really
seem to be going
and if you take a look at the viewership
numbers even after shroud ninja came on
board they certainly leave something to
be desired now as far as the hundreds of
partnered streamers that rely on mixer
for income well they say they're going
to have an opportunity to move to
Facebook gaming with their partnered
status here's what mixer had to say to
their partners in their FAQ quote thank
you for being such an integral part of
the mixer community Facebook gaming is
ready to grant you partner status and to
match your existing partner agreement as
closely as possible end quote
first I've got to say that the people I
feel the worst for in this situation are
those partnered mixer streamers that
have been completely uprooted as I'm
sure a lot of you already know it's
really hard to build a streaming
community and it gets a lot harder when
the people that like you have to go to a
completely new URL to find help even
ninja was trolling around mixer streams
last night donating the smaller
streamers to help them get through this
time yeah I need you god I need to get
it's going to be a massive adjustment
for these people and we're just gonna
have to wait and see if the transition
of Facebook really works smoothly all of
this said one of the parts of this
announcement that is pretty
underrepresented is just how aggressive
of a move this is on Facebook's part
they more or less bought all of mixers
users at what I'm guessing is a pretty
reasonable price and that's a big sign
that Facebook is looking to hang around
in the gaming space now if you're
wondering what the tech side of mixer
you know where they beat which the fact
that it looked better and the delays
weren't as long that's apparently
staying with Microsoft it's not going to
Facebook and they're gonna be using it
for you know video calls live
presentations and like meeting software
stream hatchet a website that tracks
trends and stats of streaming platforms
published this comparison of the two
websites last year and it shows even
without names like ninja Facebook has
been stealthily growth Facebook has more
unlimited money than [ __ ] Microsoft
does okay wait hold on Ron people are
people are criticizing when you said
Facebook has more money than Microsoft
Facebook has more funds to spend on
video initiative
than Microsoft though that is absolutely
true
what rod is saying there is 100% correct
so there you have one streaming platform
heralded as twitches biggest competitor
is no more some of the biggest names in
gaming are free agents and another
platform is stepping up its game all we
can really do now is sit back and watch
the speculation on Twitter and see where
shroud ninja will end up and eventually
how much more money they'll make but
before I end this video here's my takes
on where they're gonna land I think it's
pretty likely that shraddh heads back to
twitch and if I'm in Riot Games chair
right now I am stoked that he'll be
boosting valor and streaming numbers but
I have this sneaking suspicion that
ninja might actually land on YouTube
during the initial wave of streamer
signings courage JD was actually one of
the only big names to forego the live
stream first platforms and twitch and
mixer for the huge user base on YouTube
and since doing that courage has
actually seen some massive success and
in some months actually streaming to
more viewers on YouTube than he did on
Twitch and with ninja already having
more than 23 million subscribers on
YouTube I could see him joining his
buddy courage I don't know I will say I
was definitely shocked and you know I
think I think a lot of us are surprised
but I think if you look at it like a
retrospective view was retrospectively
back at the news you're like I guess I
could see this you know I personally and
I know producer Colton agrees with me I
I always felt like watching screens on
mixer was so nice but I could just never
get it to work man I could just like I
would never just like log on to my
computer when I'm chilling and be like
wow let me go see what's going on with
the trout on mixer or like you know
let's let's see if Ninja is three or
four tonight today it would it would
just always only be if I saw them tweet
something very specific and I was like
oh I need to go watch shroud and do the
play pallor until whatever